they don't care about us or our children  shame on you what was the state of gun  violence in America today it's very bad  it's been a unacceptable for a long time  I think it's increasing I definitely  think it's increasing I don't have  statistics so would reinstating the  assault weapons ban helped to bring down  the violent crime  I think reinstating the assault weapon  ban would certainly help what would it  stop the massacre would have been the  assault weapons ban there's no question  about it  so our mass shootings more frequent um  you know it seems that way I feel like I  turn on the news every day or every  other day and see you know a live feed  and b-roll of a school getting shot